Irgendwas geht bei tesla vor die daten des tesla trucks und des neuen roadsters sind so unglaublich dass bei tesla
im geheimen eine absolut neuartigen batterie und ladetechnik
Entwickelt worden sein muss denn mit der bisherigen technik ist das einfach nicht machbar
Also wie ist die lage bei tesla jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Immer wieder haben wir hiervon neuen revolutionären
batterietechnologien berichtet höhere kapazitäten schnelleres laden was da in zukunft kommt ist wirklich
Bahnbrechend wohlgemerkt in zukunft es wird noch einige jahre dauern bis es wirklichkeit werden kann
Bei tesla scheint das jetzt aber schon anders zu sein der tester truck und der roadster haben, so
unglaubliche technische daten das geht nicht ohne eine neue batterie technologie schon der russe hat absolut
wahnsinnige leistungswerte eine beschleunigung von 0 auf 100 in 1,9 sekunden
Ein porsche 918 spyder schafft es in 2,6 sekunden das ist absolut state of the art
Und selbst in der formel 1 gibt es kaum höhere werte aber bei tesla, im zwei jahren 2020
das wäre noch knapp mit aktueller technologie, zu erklären sogar 1000 kilometer reichweite
Wäre nun knapp erklärbar mit einem tesla
Akku pack und zwar dem größten mal zwei und die ersten die im neuen tesla roadster saßen berichten auch von einer erhöhten sitzposition
Indiz für ein zweites pack aber auch das ist noch nicht die lösung noch ist da nämlich
eigentlich zu wenig platz unter dem motto stadt zitat dass es heute physikalisch noch nicht möglich das sagt
elektroauto spezialist saale morsey von bloomberg new energy
Finance aber was der neue trakt aber leisten soll das ist der absolute ganze wahnwitz ein 40 tonner mit
800 kilometern reichweite in 30 minuten sondern energie für weitere 600
kilometer nach laden können wie bitte und der produktionsbeginn soll 2019 sein also in einem jahr das ist wirklich unglaublich
Und das im wahrsten sinne des wortes da staunt der laie und der fachmann wundert sich tatsächlich
kann, sich niemand diese leistung erklären der neue mega charger mit zehn mal stärker sein als der bisherige super charger zitat
Ich verstehe nicht wie das funktioniert sagt salim sie das tue ich wirklich nicht der experte von
Bloomberg new energy finance ist wirklich überfragt dort schätzt man dass der tesla semi eine batteriekapazität von 600 bis
1000 kilowattstunden haben muss das ist zehnmal mehr als die größte batterie für den tesla es im
maximalfall mit der heutigen batterietechnik würde ein solches battery pack 5 tonnen wiegen und mehr als
100.000 dollar kosten der see soll aber nur abhängig von der größe des packs 150 bis 180 tausend dollar kosten diesel
Lkw kosten nur rund
120000 dollar blumberg sagt dass diese daten nicht den aktuellen
industriestandards entsprechen viele sind der meinung dass das nur mit einem bisher geheimen fortschritt in der batterietechnologie
Möglich ist santa fe batterie experte bei köln energy research dazu
ich glaube nicht dass sie lügen ich denke dass sie etwas bei der vorstellung
ausgelassen haben was erklärt hätte wie sie auf diese zahlen gekommen sind trotzdem muss man nach der
produktionshalle beim modell 3 wo viel weniger fahrzeuge produziert werden als angekündigt wurden vorsichtig seien zwar scheint man bei tesla
Langsam die stückzahlen erhöhen zu können in der letzten dezemberwoche
Wurden 793 model 3 produziert aber hier wurde viel mehr versprochen als dann
Letztlich möglich war es bleibt also spannend bei tesla wenn nämlich wirklich diese leistungsdaten bei den neuen fahrzeugen
Erreicht werden könnten dann stehen wir wirklich vor einem quantensprung beim elektroantrieb ab 2019 könnten dann
tagesreichweiten von pkw mit
verbrennungsmotor erreicht werden die schallmauer wäre durchbrochen und damit stünde auch das elektroauto
vor dem
Endgültigen durchbruch wenn ihr mit die ersten sein wollen die von den aktuellen entwicklungen erfahren dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen
Ich den genau auf die glocke und dann werdet ihr auch über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Bald nur noch elektroautos technik vor technologiesprung da geht es genau. Um die weiterentwicklung der batterietechnologie
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran